the link between the astrazeneca vaccine
and blood clots had been a worry for
lucy and abby
in their early twenties the benefits to
them of vaccination were relatively
small
finely balanced with a risk of the side
effect now the medical regulator has
said the under 30s should be offered
an alternative vaccine instead it's
about a balance of risk
and obviously we're still quite young so
and we both are in good health and
therefore
you're kind of balancing if i do
contract covered
will i go to hospital if i do contract
it will i be fine and therefore is it
worth getting the vaccine
it's caused a bit more anxiety about it
but
now they're obviously not offering it to
young people um
yeah i definitely feel more confident
about that
20 million people have been given the
astrazeneca vaccine in the uk
up to the end of march according to a
new analysis by the medical regulator
79 had developed a blood clot unusually
at the same time as having a low level
of platelets
19 died but the prime minister urged
people not to lose faith in the jab
these vaccines are safe they've they've
saved many thousands of lives and
people should uh come forward to get
their jabs and we'll make sure that they
get the right jabs and of course uh i i
don't see
any any reason at this stage at all to
i think we need to to deviate from the
road map
and we're also very secure about
about our supply for older people the
benefit of the astrazeneca vaccine
far outweighs any risk but the young are
unlikely to become
seriously ill from the disease so the uk
regulator now recommends an
alternative jab under 30. that's at odds
with france and germany who stopped
using the vaccine in the under 55s
germany drew the line at 60 but the
deputy chief medical officer told me
they're wrong
the notion that you would um clip a
vaccine at that point is
pretty absurd really and so you know
it is very much an independent decision
but
i think it's been taken in an extremely
rational way but is that decision
driven by the availability of doses of
other vaccines
no um it isn't it absolutely wasn't
people are being urged to seek medical
attention if they develop a range of
side effects following the jab
including headaches blurred vision
breathing problems leg swelling
and skin bruising doctors who track
public confidence and vaccines say
people should be reassured but the fact
that there is a
regulatory many regulatory agencies
looking closely to it
it should be it should actually comfort
us rather than increases risk perception
means that something's being done and
the safety
systems are all there and they're all
working so what i would say is that if
you're being recommended the vaccine
after all these reviews and
and after everything has been looked at
it means that it's safe
the government says the new advice
shouldn't delay the vaccine rollout with
adults
on track to receive a first dose by the
end of july
thomas more sky news